les travailleurs temporaires et les
milliers de demandeurs d'asile
traversant actuellement le chemin Roxane
ne serait pas touché par le programme de
régularisation prévue par Ottawa selon
nos informations au grand désarroi de
certains groupes communautaires encore
une fois on leur dit désolé mais vous ne
serez pas éligibles à ces programmes
donc je pense que c'est très irritant
même pour ne pas dire scandaleux de voir
que des gens qui sont ici depuis des
années et on leur bloque encore de
pouvoir finalement je suis résident je
suis un citoyen par égal les critères
exacts ne sont pas encore fini mais le
programme toucherait les sans-papiers
donc des travailleurs avec des permis ou
des visas expirés ou encore des réfugiés
dont la demande a été refusée et qui ne
peuvent pas retourner dans leur pays
d'origine en raison d'un moratoire comme
celui décrété pour les Haïtiens et les
Afghans oui non
options
à leur accorder le statut de résident
permanent jusqu'à 500 000 personnes
pourraient être visées
sont vraiment le minimum vital donc qui
est le permis de travail ils l'ont droit
à rien d'autre est-ce que l'éventuel
programme touchera les 100 papiers du
Québec chose certaine la province à son
mot à dire en matière d'immigration on
va parler entre autres d'immigration par
François Legault c'était opposé à
élargir l'accès au programme de
régularisation du statut des anges
gardiens qui ont fourni des soins durant
les premiers mois de la pandémie le
problème c'est c'est les fameuses seuils
d'immigration c'est à dire que si on
rajoute 50
000 personnes à régulariser non ce trait
de 50 000 à 100000 du jour au lendemain
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'otawan
se prépare à lancer un tel programme de
régularisation mais jamais de cet
ampleur un nouveau gouvernement du
Québec ne s'est pas encore prononcé sur
la question ici Mélissa François
Radio-Canada Montréal